14th of October 2022 and 44 migrants are
crossing the channel to England the
Smugglers have packed them in tightly
every extra person means more cash is
[Music]
speaking in Disguise goni told us he
paid the Smugglers 3 500 euros one of
more than 12 000 albanians who've
illegally crossed to England in small
boats this year first he traveled across
Europe by car then waited in France for
the signal to go foreign
was deported back to Albania a few days
later but his story is a common one
videos of trips are easy to find on
social media as our Smugglers adverts
for cut price Crossings
oh
[Music]
and their tempting offers for many in
the northeast of Albania
this is the most deprived corner of one
of Europe's poorest countries
wages are low jobs are scarce people
want to escape
from Albania we go to Scorpio with few
prospects at home Alex is among
thousands who paid Smugglers to take him
to the UK where he worked illegally for
years if I have a chance we go right now
to England not just doing that just to
move from Albania here doesn't have no
jobs no nothing you know and you're
going to work like 10 hours from 10 10
pounds basically so it's no life here
he isn't alone most Albanian migrants
come from this area this Village of 2
000 people has dwindled to around 400
some went to the city but many escaped
abroad Albania is a small country with a
big problem the population here is
around 2.8 million yet the government
says every single year since 2011 on
average 42 000 people have left and
that's turning communities like these
into ghost towns
in the nearby city of kukas it's a
similar story
people tell us every family knows two to
three relatives living in the UK some
legally others not
so why I ask is it such a dream
destination
in UK is a good life
no kills no drugs no the smart thinking
personal thing David not his real name
tells me he got to the UK by hiding in
trucks in France he worked for five
years before being deported
some people call you criminals are you
criminals no no no no no no absolutely
no I'd want to hear that
whose Faith who say that is a liar
albanians
is not criminals
albanians is good people good culture we
work hard
absolutely yeah but you'd break the law
to go you do a legal action to go to UK
yeah illegal but everybody
we go illegal I told you for a good life
the lack of Hope here boosts the
traffickers trade the UK government says
it's working with Albania to stop the
Smugglers and speed up the removal of
migrants without the right to be in the
country but the Albanian prime minister
told me the Home secretary's recent
comments about an invasion are unhelpful
do you feel like Albania needs an
apology from the UK
when you apologize it's okay it happens
when you don't
and
when you avoid it then it means that you
want something from what you said
so it means that there is a calculation
behind it means that you you really are
talking to to to to a certain uh number
of Voters
that want to hear this and you are
feeding them with this because you need
their votes but the consequences of that
can be devastating for the people
for our people in Britain
and for Britain itself
while tens of thousands of albanians
live legally in the UK more and more are
risking their lives at sea without
renewed hope at home and better
cooperation from abroad they will keep
on coming Siobhan Robbins Sky News
Albania